[Music]
regina is with us in las vegas hi regina
how are you
hi dave hi ken thanks for taking the
call sure what's up
well i need some perspective i
appreciate the last caller because i
think you you gave me a little bit on
that call but i'm looking for some more
i'm currently on baby step two
been four years gazelle intense
and i'm going to be
looking at a court date here tomorrow
that's going to end up increasing that
debt to about the tune of 25 000
um i have literally been
developing for four years even during
covet and my gas take is on empty um i'm
just not seeing the light at the end of
the tunnel
and i don't know if i can keep up the
pace that i've been doing i have three
jobs
and i'm just my guesting is empty i'm
sorry so
i don't know if i'm looking at a
bankruptcy or if i have to do something
not stupid
i'm sorry
um how much debt have you got not
counting tomorrow
10 grand and i literally was i was
coming for a debt free scream in october
and what's your what's your income
my income is 45 a year i've upped it to
55 even during covid
but the problem i'm having is i end up
in court because all these extra
debts are attorney fees
and every time i go to court i don't
seem to be in good favor with the court
my child support is increased
so it's a very long
journey and i'm just
tired you pay child support
i do we have 50 50 custody and it
doesn't work out in my favor anytime i
go to court because he's a full-time
student making 10.50 an hour
okay and um what's the 25 000 tomorrow
tomorrow is the attorney speech for the
last two years of litigation
you owe 25 000 to an attorney
yes sir over child support
yes sir
it was because of covet it was extended
extended extended extended extended so
it's just well if he wasn't working
while it's extended why did the bill
keep going up
because my ex-husband made sure that the
bill kept going he kept putting things
in there and we kept having to respond
so you know as each response happened
it's that 250 an hour you know
so it just uh it's really spun out of
control
yeah you needed a new attorney
i'm pardon me you needed a new attorney
25 000
ago i agree with you sir but
unfortunately i gave him a retainer and
i had nothing left in the tank after
that that was my emergency fund
yeah i know
when you make 60 000 and you spend 25
000 on child support that's not in
balance that's uh
i totally agree with you sir
i'm not fussing at you i'm just crying
with you
oh please fuss at me oh you don't need
to be fussed at you you've gotten fussed
out enough um you just got a mask kiddo
so you owe the attorney's fees and the
attorney has sued you for the fees
yeah tomorrow is the day we go to the
judge we've stayed off we've done
everything to try and
yeah you're going to lose because the
money yeah exactly yeah yeah i'm going
to leave yeah well you owe the money i
mean it's not a it's not not there's not
really a thing to you know he sucks as
an attorney is not a defense
um right for the debt for the attorney
fees i mean you took them on so um
yes
and this guy
knows that you make 60 000 a year
he represented me for two and a half
years and he knows that you don't have
any
knows that where money he think what
does he think this is going to
accomplish do we have any idea
i truly don't know i just guess he wants
to garnish my wages which is going to
basically leave me and my daughter in a
big deficit yeah it's going to change
our world yeah
so
do you have uh i'm looking for
options i guess with perspective
um
i would just tell him that we're either
going to have to work something out
that is a tremendous discount and i'll
go scrape some money together and give
you a lump sum at a tremendous discount
or i'm going to help you to get zero
because that's called a chapter 7
bankruptcy
and and that's kind of what i did on my
own because i knew what i was up against
you told him that
yeah i basically said you know what i
have and you can go forward with this
but you know what's going to happen
and i basically you know laid it on to
him and he pushed he pushed the button
so i'm looking at this bankruptcy head
on and i just i want to know i'm doing
the right thing
trying to stay a step a step above and
a step ahead for my daughter's sake
um
well i i would i always tell folks if
you're gonna file bankruptcy and i'm
i never recommend it it's a horrible
process to go through but if you're
going to
make sure you've tried every single
thing you can try
before you do it because i it is a
life-altering thing it's in the same
category as a divorce
it's something you want to avoid if
there's any way you can so you try
everything now you've tried almost
everything here but here's the thing he
even if he gets the judgment tomorrow
and he probably will
um
then he has to act on it and until he
actually does act on it
it just sits there well he's he's pushed
the motion to put in a he's already
filed the motion to garnish my wages so
like but there's not even a judgment is
there a judgment already
well we put a stay on it my
understanding
you know the day the garnishment hits
that might be the day that you make your
decision that you've done everything you
can do
well the day the garnishment hits i'm
going to have to move i mean i'm i'm
that tight no
no no no no no no no if you file chapter
7 bankruptcy there's no garnishment it
goes away
i understood okay so i'm saying if he if
he actually does do that
not just threatens it and so what we
want to be careful of the is that we've
we've you know one more time i'll talk
to him one more time i'll say listen if
you do this and just say it out loud
just say
you're not getting a garnishment okay i
had this negotiation one time i was
negotiating for a
a business guy that had a bank debt with
a local bank and i'm sitting with the
banker and the banker says we're going
to foreclose on the property which
obviously for a bankruptcy stops a
foreclosure
and um i said no you're not he goes oh
yeah i am yeah i am no
we're either going to there's two
options we're either going to work out
something as we sit here
with you guys and negotiate out some
kind of settlement
or the guy's going into a chapter 11
bankruptcy
or a seven bankruptcy but you're not
foreclosing on the property i can keep
you from foreclosing on the property so
let's establish that you're not going to
foreclose
now
it's either because of a bankruptcy or
because we work something out so which
which one do you want to do it's your
choice
because well and then it comes well
we're going to foreclose i'm like dude
you're not real smart are you what i
just said was we're not going you're not
going to be allowed to foreclose your
federal court is going to stop you or
you're going to come to an agreement
today but foreclosure is not going to
occur that's the type of conversation i
would have with this attorney okay
there's not going to be a garnishment
either
i'm going to stop you with a chapter 7
and you're going to get zero in that
case or you and i work something out
and you know and then but that and those
type of
ultimatum discussions in a negotiation
are sometimes the last thing you can do
and you want to do everything you can do
to try to avoid this you've fought so
hard you've come so close and it would
be a bloody shame
for this one thing to take you down yeah
and practically speaking here whatever
the amount is i'm assuming dave that the
lawyer has shared what the amount is the
garnish would be and so we got a figure
so if he's going to get anything it's
that number or less that he agrees to
and then you look at okay can i keep
doing three three jobs it doesn't sound
like she can do three more jobs i mean
three jobs much more right her tank is
empty as well our tank's empty because
she just keeps getting piled on yeah but
if she can push through and manage to
make that money a better second job a
better paying second job that's that
last resort to okay if i can settle this
with this guy and not go into bankruptcy
i'll give him five grand cash and go
borrow it
that's interesting yeah you know that's
what i'd cause you know really have 25
i'd rather five grand death than 25 yeah
that's true but i mean we'll settle with
just one way or another here but try
some stuff like that regina because
sometimes these guys
they just you have to explain it to them
they don't smart sometimes